המשימה הבאה שלנו זה בעצם ה אה רגע צריך
לכבות את הדבר הזה
למה הזכרת לו
המשימה הבאה שלנו זה בעצם א הגנה בנהר
אליטני
א כל החטיבה בעצם המשימה שלה הייתה לטפס
לזהר מזותר השרקיע וזותר הגרביע א בוחה א
שאר הכפרים ארנון יוחמור וגם בראי שלנו זה
היה גם נבתיה א והוחלט שהפלוגה שלי נשארת
בהגנה א בתוך הנהר למטה מתוך הבנה שהבעצם
ה
יש א נכס חיוני שנקרא מעבר אמטיסט דרכו א
עובר את בעצם כל העוגדה א באותו נכון
לאותו זמן עד שפתחו עוד מעברים וכו אבל א
יש שם בעצם מעבר הכרחי שחייב להגן עליו
והפלוגה מקבלת את המשימה אנחנו בעצם
מגיעים לנהר אין יתורים אין אה
אין צירים אין עכשיו איזה משהו שהיינו
רגילים אליו ואנחנו נדרשים בעצם לחזור
ליסודות לעשות הגנה בשטח סבוך עם עמדות
ירים עמדות הסתתרות עמדות שייה א ובעצם
אנחנו נכנסים שם להגנה א על פי הטול בחירת
השטחים, בחירת נתיבי החדירה א בחירת
הדפעות של האויב ומתחילים להערך אל מול
הדפעות שאנחנו מבינים שיהיו שם א והיה לי
מאוד מאוד חשוב להסביר למפקדים כי הרבה
פעמים אנחנו חושבים שבגלל שאמצאנו ובאמת
אמצאנו המון דברים חדשים בלחימה ועמלך חדש
וכו אז לפעמים אנחנו חשוב מאוד לחזור לטול
ולהבין שנייה שהמציאו
את הדברים האלה לפנינו. המציאו כבר כתבו
איך עושים קרב הגנה ולחזור לעקרונות
ההגנה, הקפיות, הדדיות. אה
וככה באמת עשינו. הגענו ולצורך העניין עם
הדדיות הבנו שכדי שתהיה הדדיות בין שתי
אגדות אנחנו צריכים לייצר לנו איזשהו
מעבר. אז ביוזמתו של אותו ממם שדיברנו
עליו כבר ממחו הדרכים אנחנו בונים גשר.
גשר חיר מעל הליטני.
עם ברזלים שמצאנו וכל מיני גדרות
ופשוט יוצרים מעבר חיר שאפשר לנו להעתיק
את העתודה שלנו לאן שאנחנו רוצים. תפקידה
של התודה בהגנה זה לחזק מאמץ נחשל. אז
אמרנו מה קורה אם עכשיו בגדה אחת צריך את
העזרה של העתודה? אבל היא בצד השני. אז
יצרנו מעבר א שבאמת אפשר לנו מעבר מהיר
בין אגדות בלי לעשות את כל העיקוף. א
פטרולים עלימים.
וצריך גם להגיד שההצלחה הכי גדולה שלנו שם
בעיניי כפלוגה זה שכל הרחפנים שעברו
ועברו בעצם נהר הליטני הוא כמו אוטוסטרדה
של רחפנים הם היו מזדתרים על בסיס הטו של
הנחל א ואף רחפן באמת לא מתנפץ עלינו תודה
לאל א כנראה לא זיהו אותנו בתוך הסו א וזה
היה כל פעם שדבר כזה קורה כזה נש הנחת
רווחה אה א וגם זה היה נותן לנו יכולת
להטריע שאנחנו רואים רחפן לפני שהוא מגיע
למעבר או מגיע לעומק הגזרה. אז זה גם ככה
היה יתרון שאנחנו נמצאים שם
ושם היינו בעצם שלושה שבועות. שלושה
שבועות אנחנו בהגנה
נדרשים כל פעם להמציא את עצמנו מחדש ועוד
פטרול ועוד איזשהיא יזומה ועוד איזשהו
מוקש תאורה ועוד איזשהו נתם שאנחנו
סוגרים.
א
וכשהתקופה הזאת נגמרת אנחנו מגיעים בעצם
למשימה האחרונה שעשינו
שזה השמדת הלו שלוש.
אוקיי? זה בעצם הסיפור האחרון
כן
שזה בעצם פרקתם את ה9 טון לתוך הסיפור
הזה.
איזה 9 טון?
זה מה שמספר א
272. חצי טון.
רק הפלוגה שלך?
הפלוגה שלי ביחד עם א
פלוגה ג' של 607 ויהלום.
272. ח טון לתוך הטו.
סבבה. וזה בעצם האירוע האחרון שלכם.
זה האירוע האחרון. כן. קדימה ספר.
א לא סיפרתי על יארי. אתה חושב שזה
יערי? מה במה זה היה?
הוא לא היה איתי אבל הוא חייל שלי. כאילו
באיזה אירוע הוא נהרג?
הוא נהרג ב בחפק מחבית חפק בזמן שאנחנו
בנחל.
לא לא זה לא סיפור זה סיפור.
אז אני לא נוגע בזה. לא נוגע בזה.
א בעצם המשימה זה להכניס בידיים
35,000 ג'ריקיינים בחישוב שכבר כל הפלוגיה
יודעת לשרוק אותו 272 טון א לתוך טו מטורף
זה בעצם פעם ראשונה שאנחנו רואים כזו
מנהרה ראינו מנהרות בעזה וראינו גם בלבנון
אבל מנהרה כזאת גדולה שאתה יכול לנסוע
בתוכה עם טרקטור א או עם איזשהו אופנוע א
חדרי ניתוח
בתוך ה בתוך המנהרה עם עם בלוני חמצן ועם
שמי הרדמה ועם מיטות ניתוח ועם מטבח ועם
המון אמלך וכמות אוכל ומים באמת מטורפת
א ואת הדבר הזה אנחנו צריכים להשמיד א
ואני חושב שהמשימה הזאתי באה לנו כמו כפפה
ליד א אחרי שלושה שבועות בתוך הנהר שאתה
יחסית בשעות היום אתה יחסית סטטי ובערב
אתה עושה פטרולים אבל אתה אתה לא פעיל כמו
שאתה פעיל עכשיו בהשמדות שעשינו בעין אתה
וכו אז פתאום משימה כזאתי שהיא מאוד מאוד
פיזית א
זה משימה שהיא גם הייתה מאוד ערכית
בעינינו וידענו גם להגיד את זה לחיילים
ולתוווח את זה
וגם אמרנו אוקיי זה כמו אימון עכשיו שלושה
שבועות לא התאמנו היינו בסבב מאוד ארוך
ועכשיו יש לנו זכינו שבוע של אימון כל יום
לסחוב 16 קילו בנגלות
לתוך המנהרה הזאת
ובאמת כל יום קמים בבוקר
ומתחילות להגיע משאיות. בכל משאית יש בערך
800 ג'ריקאנים. א בוא נגיד שהפיק זה היה
ימים של שמונה משאיות בכל יום, תשע מסאות
בכל יום. א ועובדים ומתחילים להכניס ועוד
טון ועוד טון ועוד משאית ועוד שתי משאיות.
וככה בעצם הכנסנו ביחד עם עוד פלוגה מ-607
אה ועם א יחידת יהלום. הכנסנו 270 טון
לתוך הטווי א ואני חושב שכשידענו
להסביר לחיילים אני והמפקדים להגיד להם
חבר'ה אתם עכשיו כל נגלה אנחנו רוצים
שתסתכלו על הידיים שמרימות את הג'ריקלים
ותגידו אני א אוחנה מקריית גת לצורך
העניין משמיד עכשיו טווי שהאיראנים שמו
עליו המון כסף ובנו אותו במשך מעל 15 שנה
אני הדרי מאפולה משמיד עכשיו בידיים שלי
את הדבר הזה זה ברגע שהחיילים הבינו את
זה, לא שמענו תלונות, לא שמענו
התבכיינויות, לא ראינו אנשים מנסים עכשיו
לברוח מהמשימה, כולם קמים בבוקר, באים
לעבוד, באים, כל אחד אומר, אני עכשיו
משמיד את את המאמץ הגדול הזה של האיראנים,
של חזבלה
וגם צריך כאילו עם כמה שהמשימה הייתה קשה,
באמת פיזית מאוד קשה, אתה כבר מגיע לארבע
שעות עבודה, אתה גמור, אתה רק רוצה לשתות
מים ולשבת במזגן
ועובדים עובדים ועובדים עד שסיימנו את
המשימה
גם צריך להגיד כושר גופני זה משהו שהוא
חשוב וזה באמת היה כמו אימון. אימון קשה
אבל אימון וגם משימה מאוד ערקית אז
גם חצי בלבנון
וגם חצי ב' בלבנון
מועד מספר וזה מסיים המועד מספר שהתקשרת
אליו ואמרת לו מגד אני חייב לבוא לראות את
החיילים עובדים הוא אומר הוא היה מוטש הוא
היה אחרי אתה יודע שהלך לו הרצינג וזה
הגעתי לשמ חיילים עובדים אומר תשמע
התמלאתי נתן לי כוח חידש אותי רגע
כן באמת אה היה לי את השיחה הזאת עם אה עם
המגד שאמרתי לו תשמע תבוא לפה רק תראה איך
החבר'ה הולכים איך הם עובדים באיזה רבק
באיזה זה ואיזה נגלות ופה ושם ובאמת המגד
מגיע הוא הגיע עם המחת והגיע עם עוד כמה
עם מפקד יהלום א ובאמת הם הם ראו את את
העבודה ותשמע גם לי אני אני מאמין שעל אחת
כמה וכמה לדרג של מגד או אחת שהם רואים את
הדבר הזה גם לי כמפי שאני חי עם האנשים
האלה כל יום לראות אותם א אל מול משימה
שהיא לא פשוטה. זה לא פשוט. עכשיו א אתה
יודע אין אוויר וחשוך א ויש לחות כזאת
וכוכשהאנפו
מתפורר הוא מעלה גז שלא כיף לנשום אותו
ואתה משתעל והאנשים עובדים והנה ההוא נשרט
רגע ביד והוא ממשיך וההוא נפל על הברך
וכואב לו והוא ממשיך
ואנשים באמת נכנסו לאטרף של אנחנו חייבים
להשמיד את הדבר הזה אנחנו חייבים לעשות את
הדבר הזה וגם הם הבינו ש אה ככל שבעצם א
יש לזה סוף אז ככל שתעבוד יותר חזק וקשה
אתה גם תסיים יותר מהר. אז אנשים באמת
עבדו שם כמו משוגעים וזה היה כיף. זה היה
כיף לראות אותם
וגם לחזור לאיתור שאתה כולך גמור ועבדת
קשה. זה תחושה טובה.
תשמע, החוכמה הגדולה היא לקחת את זה עכשיו
בשגרה.
אני הולכים להתפרק לכם אחי ברס